[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue nous nous retrouvons pour cette
nouvelle édition autour de deux invités
qui sont médecins mais pas que loin de
là bonsoir laurent alexandre prat vous
êtes donc médecins chirurgiens mais
aussi entrepreneur essayiste et votre
dernier livre jouissez jeunesse a été
publié aux éditions lattès puis nous
accueillons aussi le docteur patrick
pleau médecin urgentiste vous le disiez
avant qu'on commence que vous vous étiez
dans des renforts de réanimation ans
mourait à saint-antoine
bah ouais c'est un plaisir de retrouver
les équipes de saint-antoine et dans
l'unité de soins continus polar et quand
vous n'êtes pas avec votre blouse au
chevet des malades vous écrivez aussi
votre dernier livre urgence de vivre a
été publié aux éditions du cherche midi
si nous commençons par parler de cette
interview fleuve du président de la
république dans le figaro de ce matin
emmanuel macron à fait à la fois un
bilan et esquisser un programme de ce
qui pourrait être son projet sur les
sujets régaliens pour un nouveau
quinquennat est l'une des parties cette
interview a spécialement retenu notre
attention
le président de la république s'y montre
très opposés à une légalisation du
cannabis voici un extrait de son propos
dire que le haschich est innocent et
plus qu'un mensonge affirme le président
de la république sur le plan cognitif
les effets sont désastreux ceux qui
prennent de la drogue doivent comprendre
que non seulement ils mettent leur santé
en danger mais qu'ils alimentent aussi
le plus grand des trafics on se roule un
joint dans son salon et à la fin on
alimente la plus importante des sources
d'insécurité
voilà c'est dit et les propos qui sont
d'autant plus forts qu'eux emmanuel
macron n'a pas toujours eu ce point de
vue écoutez cette interview qu'il
donnait en septembre 2016 il était à
l'époque donc candidat à la présidence
de la république et il
voyez bien qu'elle pouvait être les
avantages d'une légalisation du cannabis
cannabis pose un problème en effet de
sécurité de lien avec la délinquance
dans des quartiers difficiles de
financement de réseaux occultes
et donc on voit bien que la légalisation
du cannabis à des intérêts de ce point
de vue et à une forme d'efficacité
et notamment pour justifier son propos
dans l'interview du figaro le président
de la république rappelle l'ampleur des
trafics qui sont liées au cannabis et
l'importance du trafic de drogue pour
expliquer l'insécurité de certains
quartiers est ce que vous êtes
convaincus par cette démonstration
laurent alexandre emmanuel macron change
d'avis parce qu'on est proche de
l'élection présidentielle et que comme
il n'y a aucun danger
à gauche on a vu que anne hidalgo est à
5% dans les sondages
le vrai danger l'état droite c'est
l'émergence d'un candidat de droite
candidat de l'ordre qui pourrait être au
second tour donc ils droitise sa
position sur ce sujet où la droite est
très anti âge alors que la gauche est
traditionnellement plutôt pro h
donc je pense qu'il ya des arrière
pensées politiques dans les déclarations
du président de la république en tant
que père de famille je suis un anti âge
forcené je crois avoir convaincu tous
mes enfants de ne pas consommer 2 h
moi personnellement je n'ai jamais fumé
un seul joints de toute ma vie
ça paraît complètement ridicule mais non
mais qu on est au moins deux sur ce
plateau ça m'a permis au redémarrage
salamé 3 joue tout de suite face à wolf
a davantage quand on n'a jamais pris de
juin on n'est pas en état de manque on
ne regrette pas parce que comme on n'a
jamais goûté on ne sait pas ce que c'est
donc c'est une façon de se protéger soi
même et est donc j'ai convaincu les
enfants mais en tant que médecin cette
fois ci il ya une vraie question qui
d'ailleurs évoqué par le président de la
république dans ses propos c est ce que
c'est vraiment mauvais pour le cerveau
le cannabis ou pas alors eh ben ayad il
ya trois choses il ya l'intelligence il
ya la mémoire il ya les troubles
psychologiques
alors sur l'intelligence on a longtemps
cru que le cannabis diminue et le
quotient intellectuel
en réalité ce n'est pas le cas il ya
trois études qui ont montré qu'en
réalité c'était un biais d' analyse
c'est que les enfants qui sont des gros
fumeurs de haschich au moins intelligent
avant même d'avoir pris le 1er juin est
donc entre les gros consommateur de
haschich et les autres il y as avant de
devenir consommateurs 6.2 quotient
intellectuel de différence donc ce n'est
pas le haschisch
moins intelligent c'est que les gamins
moins intelligents ont plus de chances
de devenir gros consommateur de haschich
en revanche sur la mémoire
là il est prouvé que le haschich diminue
la mémoire et sur les effets
psychologiques
il est prouvé que le haschich est pas
bon il augmente le risque de
schizophrénie il augmente le risque de
dépression chronique donc globalement le
haschich ne rend pas plus con mais il
diminue la mémoire et il augmente les
troubles psychiatriques donc le bilan
n'est pas bon idéalement il faudrait que
nos gamins ne consomme pas de haschisch
mais comme vous le savez la lutte contre
le haschich à l'échelle mondiale elle a
échoué et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on
se repose régulièrement la question de
la dépénalisation oui parce qu'à
l'aspect sanitaire patrick peloux
l'aspect purement médical dont on vient
de parler
laurent alexandre et puis il ya aussi
toutes les conséquences sécuritaires de
du trafic de cannabis
bien sûr c'est intéressant parce que ce
que dit laurent alexandre j'avais pas en
fait capté le message politique
pourquoi j'étais convaincu que emmanuel
macron elle dira le contraire
pour quelle raison parce qu'il y a une
mission d'information au cas lieu
actuellement à l'assemblée nationale et
qu'ils sont allés très en avant par
rapport à ces propositions là ça
m'étonnait c'est enfin je suis assez
étonné de la réaction d' emmanuel macron
ce jeudi convaincu qu'il allait profiter
de cette mission d'information pour dire
faut légaliser dépénaliser alors on a un
exemple là sous nos yeux c'est aux états
unis où ça aide le cannabis a été rendu
voilà loi du marché premier état à
l'avoir fait le colorado en une année
ils ont remboursé les impôts aux
américains tellement ça rapporte et
d'argent grâce aux taxes grâce aux taxes
ils sont allés jusqu'à dire au dealer
notoire qu'il y avait ok on fait table
rase mais vous ouvrez des boutiques vous
reconnaissez les trucs et c'est donc une
espèce de passation du coup les autres
états ont suivi notamment la californie
il se trouve que j'étais en californie
au moment où ils disent
franchi le pas ou sont apparus des
boutiques avec green shops etc avec des
tas d'indications assez de ça vous a pas
donné envie de goûter non pas du tout
pas du tout on comprend mieux maintenant
j'ouvre une parenthèse mais les gens qui
fument ne fume pas de cannabis sont plus
intelligents savez pour ça non je veux
continuer je termine donc d'un coup ils
ont franchi le pas par rapport à cette
prohibition parce qu'il s'agit d'une
véritable prohibition d'accord la
première proposition et c'est
probablement ce dont l'histoire reste à
vie c'était l'alcool un bond d'un coup
ça les a marqués et probablement que là
ils ont franchi un cap nous on n'arrive
pas à franchir ce cap
or on sait ce que vous venez de dire est
qu'ils sont en fait les plus grands
opposants à la légalisation
dépénalisation du cannabis ce sont les
dealers parce qu'évidemment il se disent
les milliards parce qu'on parle bien de
milliards il s'agit là de bercy qui a
fait des évaluations alors on est à
presque 40 50 milliards en ça dépend des
chics des périodes etc
mais en gros ça fait un pactole qui est
dans cette économie souterraine
parallèle aérienne tellement elle paraît
surdimensionné et la peur c'est pour ça
que la gauche bien pensante ne voulait
pas dire qu'elle légalise et en se
disant mais on pourra jamais rétablir
l'aide sociale qui est fait par les
dealers dans les quartiers alors moi moi
je crois qu'une société qui s'assume et
qui va vers la modernité est une société
qui assume ses vices et qui sait les
encadrer c'est pour ça que moi je crois
et alors là on a maintenant des études
grandeur nature parce qu'évidemment aux
états unis des champions des études sont
tous regardés au colorado en californie
là ils viennent d'accepter la
légalisation des pénalisations à new
york
donc tout le monde surveille en fait il
n'y a pas eu d'augmentation des malades
on sait notamment dans le parkinson
l'intérêt du cannabis
on sait l'intérêt du cannabis dans les
soins palliatifs donc c'est juste une
question de nuances mais par rapport aux
remarques vous que vous avez fait que tu
as fait tout à l'heure sur la mémoire
etc
j'oppose à chaque fois évidemment c'est
un peu tarte à la crème mais c'est la
réalité
un alcool donc du coup moi à mon sens il
vaudrait mieux franchir le pas tout
encadré que cet argent revienne dans le
bien commun qu'ils soient divisés en
trois avec de l'argent pour l'éducation
pour en effet apprendre à ne pas
on est d'accord dans le soin dans la
justice et la police est évidemment
parce que ça c'est hyper important sur
l'aide sociale des quartiers en faisant
quoi sur cette audi social ça veut dire
quoi
mais aider les familles les familles qui
sont qui sont violentes
psychologiquement ou physiquement les
aider trouver des nouveaux moyens on
peut pas si vous voulez le fond et pour
terminer on peut pas continuer
actuellement à rivaliser avec des
économies souterraines dans des
quartiers où vous avez le chômage où
vous avez l'un brandon social vous avez
l'abandon culturel et le seul idéal pour
les gamins c'est de se dire tu vas être
dealer ça va être génial tu vas garder
gagner de l'argent il oublie juste de
dire qu'il a une espérance de vie de
trente ans d'accord et ça ça il faut
lutter contre ça je regrette c'est et
c'est dommage parce que enfin mais je
comprends le message j'avais pas vu
comme ça donc merci c'est qu'en fait il
a donné un message sur le fait qu ils
égalisaient pas est dépénalisée pas à la
droite classique qui en fait en disant
il faut pas légaliser des pédales j'ai
fait le jeu des dealers de la
délinquance rappelons juste qu'à peu
près deux tiers des personnes qui sont
en taule c'est de près ou de loin lié au
trafic de stups ans mais on peut
néanmoins être contre la légalisation
sans vouloir faire le jeu des dealers en
considérant par exemple si on considère
que c'est mon rêve
il faut oser poser l'interdît you seval
cole c'est l'alcool est mauvais et
pourtant on accepte sa consommation et
les gamins en réalité ils ont une
quantité illimitée du haschich
tiens il faut pas penser que la
situation actuelle conduit les gamins à
moins consommer ces gamins qui veulent
continuer 20 juin par bus par jour c'est
d'azo ils ont dû aller c est cette
hauteur de 20 juin par c'est un échec
la mission est un échec imaginez non
mais juste juste écouter ce chiffre il
ya 10 milliards qui tombe à l'éducation
nationale là demain bon d'accord on a
réglé le problème de location alors là
pour le coup on peut augmenter les
salaires des enseignants divisé de
classe par deux et avoir l'objectif de
dire voilà vous enseigner le non
consommés ou le consommer avec
modération si tel est le cas notamment
pour l'alcool et on
on progressera il faut nécessairement
cette société doit bouger et et
progresser sur ces sur ses addictions
les internautes du figaro sont très
partagés il ya vraiment un débat vif qui
est en cours à propos de ce sujet sur
notre fil twitter mais aussi sur
lefigaro.fr et sur youtube
emmanuel macron at il raison de ne pas
vouloir légaliser le cannabis
et bien c'est une approbation à 56% mais
dans les points de vue on retrouve cette
divergence vole pas eu 34
il a 100% raison de ne pas légaliser par
contre il faut chasser plus sérieusement
les trafiquants c'est de la drogue dit
jean-françois sur twitter donc c'est
mauvais il est inconcevable de légaliser
la prise de drogues douces opa douce
c'est de la drogue
et puis on a contrario pop sur
lefigaro.fr considère qu'avec 3 millions
du teil d'utilisateurs réguliers en
france il n'y a aucune chance d'arriver
à quoi que ce soit il faut légaliser
ajoute-t-il comme l'alcool c'est la dose
qui fait la dangerosité
fanfan ajoute sur youtube partout dans
le monde où la légalisation été fait il
ya eu des milliers d'emplois créés des
milliards de bénéfices et la chute des
trafics
je n'y vois que du bon je n'ai jamais
fumé ni cannabis ni tabanou 10r 34 0 66
c'est une question de volonté les
dealers vendront de la cocaïne ou pire
sas à margut mans sécuritaire souvent
employé laurent exemple c'est de dire
c'est pas parce que vous légaliser le
cannabis que les les dealers vont se
mettre à suivre un cap2 de mécanique
appliquée et que donc ils feront
d'autres trafics pour continuer à gagner
autant de rabbins c'est sûr quand on est
des dealers et qu'on gagne 250 mille
euros par an sans impôt sur le revenu
d'aller à l'usiné
le jour où on dépénalise le haschich
c'est de tout à fait démoralisant donc
il va bien falloir trouver des emplois
de substitution aux dealers donc soit
les dealers vont aller vers d'autres
drogues
soit ils vont aller vers le grand
banditisme web et faux pas ou pas du
coup on règle pas les problèmes de
sécurité non baba parti comme ça on va
pas les régler parce qu'en plus de ça ce
qu'il faut quand même dire c'est que
l'argent de la drogue sert l'argent de
l'islamisme un d'accord faut pas oublier
la sa le lien entre le terrorisme et le
est la seule activité qui a eu des ch en
syrie
c'était de continuer a dit les largement
les champs de pavot donc il faut pas
faut pas se voiler la face il ya
vraiment une question alors c'est à moi
je trouve que c'est intéressant de
lancer le débat politique là dessus
parce que c'est c'est une vraie échéance
politique mais on peut pas dire qu'il se
passe rien à travers la planète puisque
vous avez la plus grande puissance du
monde s'il y en a une d'ailleurs on sait
plus mais les états unis qui l'a fait
alors vous n'avez pas de débordements
j'ajouterai une chose puisque vous
mettez en avant
enfin vous were je sais pas quoi mais
met en avant l'ère 34 0 66
lorsque nous ont dit nos identités
hugues 10h34 je maintiens contraire 34
mais ça serait bien que tout le monde
avance à visage découvert mais bon autre
sujet mais le
le truc c'est que l'on met en avant la
santé il faut savoir que quand il fume
du shit c'est à dire la résine de
cannabis
il ya n'importe quoi dedans il ya
souvent des adjuvants qui sont issus du
kérosène ou des trucs comme ça donc vous
les gamins aux jeunes générations sont
en train de fumer des choses qui sont
extrêmement dangereuses pour la santé
d'accord dont les volets aux urgences
ces gens là très rarement très rarement
l'intoxication cannabis très rarement
généralement c'est intriqués avec
l'alcool et là où on les voit c'est
quand ils font canal cocaïne cannabis
pour se calmer alcool cocaïne alors là
on les voit d'accord mais c'est
généralement à truquer mais le fumeur de
joints non il chante des chansons de
gréement white et puis il voyait il
n'est pas dangereux
voyez bon mais le le cru le truc c'est
que il fume des produits pourris qui
vous les retrouverez en fin de compte au
bout de la chaîne de la santé publique
puisque se rendent malades avec des
cancers épouvantable due notamment aux
hydrocarbures qui sont dans ces trucs là
donc moi je crois que à partir du moment
où on créerait des filières en effet on
créerait de l'emploi des produits de
qualité et on encadrerait c'est la même
question est la même problématique avec
l'alcool qui est la première des drogues
en france
est ce que ces gens qui sont opposés à
sa sont en train de vous dire mais
finalement revenons à une prohibition de
l'alcool mais vous vous d'un possible et
on s'arrête là alors alexandre est ce
que ce raisonnement vous le vous
pourriez le tenir au 6 pour la cocaïne
ou le crack
moi je suis opposé à la consommation de
haschich mais je suis pour la
dépénalisation la consommation est trop
importante en france pour qu'on la
supprime
ils nous aident et la prohibition et est
impensable donc il faut encadrer
organisé taxés et puis m quelques cars 2
deux crs dans les banlieues qui vont
bouillonner lorsque les dealers vont
voir leur revenu divisé par 100 mais je
vous assure quand vous regardez ce qui
se passe aux etats unis enfin ils ont
tellement eu même économiste en sont
parvenues de l'argent qui est arrivé
avec ça et c'est probablement une des
raisons de la gangrène des banlieues
voilà pas si vous le voulez bien un
autre sujet sanitaire mais lier cette
fois à la pandémie peut être avez vous
suivi les mésaventures de ce
vaccinodromes ce centre de vaccination
ouvert à nice qui devait fonctionner
tout le week-end y avait quatre mille
doses d'astrazeneca qui était prête à
être injectés sauf que il n'y a eu que
58 personnes qui se sont présentées pour
se faire vacciner et du coup le centre a
fermé à l'heure du déjeuner samedi faute
de candidats d'où la question que nous
nous posons et si on ouvrait la
vaccination à tout le monde on sait
qu'aujourd'hui il faut avoir plus de 55
ans pour l'astra zeneca plutôt que de
jeter les doses et si on ouvrait le
nombre de gens
possiblement vaccinable laurent
alexandre c'est une bonne idée ou pas
alors ce qui s'est passé vaccinodromes
est tout à fait désolant mais il se
trouve qu'on avait médiatisé le fait que
c'était des astra zeneca et on a
convaincu l'opinion que le vaccin
astrazeneca est extrêmement dangereux ce
qui n'est pas le cas
moi ma femme je les envoyer se faire
vacciner à l'astra zeneca cet après midi
elle a été elle a été vaccinée à 14h30 à
la strazeele et cas et elle va bien et
elle se porte comme un charme très
joliment siècle astrazeneca était
dangereux je n'y aurais pas envoyer ma
femme moi j'ai eu droit ou father
d'ailleurs vaccinés par parle par notre
ami mais parce qu'à l'époque j'avais pas
d'astrazeneca mais s'il y avait eu de
l'astra zeneca j'en aurais pris donc là
là on a on paye la communication
désastreuse sur l'astra zeneca l'europe
qui a paniqué qui happe et auch et il ya
un mois
l'incapacité du pouvoir politique
d'assumer le fait que il ya
effectivement quelques accidents
extrêmement rare mais que la balance et
penche en faveur du vaccin
donc on en paie on en paye ce prix là et
ça vient d'assez loin
souvenez vous cette interview lunaire du
président macron le 4 décembre dernier
où il insistait sur le danger des
vaccins le 4 décembre à un tir que le
gouvernement était très hésitant sur la
vaccination il a toujours fait passer
des messages inquiets et je ne parle
même pas des interviews de fisher
monsieur gouvernement monsieur vaccin du
gouvernement fin décembre donc les
français qui sont les plus vaccinaux
inquiet du monde les plus anti vaccins
du monde ont été inquiétés par l'état et
puis la communication autour de l'astra
n'a pas été bonne on n'a pas su rassurer
mais sur le principe a expliqué ce qu'il
faut signer tout le monde c'est exact
cynodrome et été et est évident est-ce
qu'il faut vacciner tout le monde
moi franchement je préfère qu'on fait
ici qu'on finisse de vacciner les jambes
75 ans que de commencer à vacciner les
gamins quand on sait que les gens de 75
ans ils ont cent quatre-vingt deux fois
plus de chances de mourir que les gamins
de 20 à 30 ans quand ils font un
qu'ovide donc je pense qu'il est
raisonnable aujourd'hui de mettre le
paquet sur les vieux il faut savoir que
dans les ehpad en france il n'y a que 6
départements au moment où nous parlons
où on a atteint 90% de vaccination
il n'y a que six dans 95 départements
français en comptant les territoires
d'outre-mer
dans 95 départements français on est en
dessous de 9 personnes âgées dépendantes
sur 10 vacciner donc on n'a pas fini de
vacciner les gens fragiles non
franchement je pense qu'il faut
continuer de mettre le paquet sur les
vols entre agile et généraliser la
vaccination un peu plus tard quand les
gens fragiles seront protégés je
constate au passage que nos internautes
sont majoritairement désaccord avec vous
laurent alexandre on vous interroge sur
twitter pensez vous qu'il est temps
d'ouvrir la vaccination à tous les
volontaires et c'est oui à 89% quel est
votre point de vue patrick pelouse
puisque je vais pas dire ça parce que
les jeux pour une fois twitter est
d'accord avec moi je suis d'accord avec
eux pourquoi pourquoi parce que je
réagis en tant que médecin mais mais
comme toi je réagis en tant que médecin
pour avoir l'honneur de servir en
réanimation et au samu de paris
toutes les personnes qu'on prend en
charge qui sont avec deco vide de
moyenne gravité ou de gravité extrême
n'ont pas été vaccinés est donc là à
l'heure actuelle ce qui se passe parce
qu'on est quasiment la taille enfin on
est la deuxième quinzaine d'avril je ne
je n'ai de cesse de me dire mais si ils
avaient été vaccinées il en serait pas
là parce que tout ce qu'on a
n'ont pas été vaccinés donc ce vaccin
fonctionne on a une baisse réelle on
n'est pas sur les mêmes schémas qui a un
an parce qu on a vacciné peu ou prou pas
assez c'est évident mais nous avons
vacciné les personnes âgées c'est vrai
que le virus a déjà fait avec la
faucheuse un premier tour donc en a
plein qui sont décédés mais ce qu on a
vacciné
on ne les revoit pas donc ce vaccin est
efficace
ces vaccins sont efficaces y compris
l'astra et des cas j'ai été vacciné
aufhaeuser parce qu'avec les équipes du
samu ont été les premiers à être
vaccinés parce qu'on était en première
ligne et avec ce vaccin là si
aujourd'hui j'avais pas été vaccinés
j'aurais pris l'astra zédé cas puisque
vous avez proportionnellement et il faut
le savoir pourquoi on a le vidal qui est
un bouquin gros comme ça c'est parce que
tous médicaments que vous prenez ya un
risque
et si vous commencez à lire tous les
risques par exemple des chimiothérapie
des cancers
eh ben on sauve plus
personne des cancers parce qu'en effet
vous avez des contre indications des
effets indésirables
c'est inhérent à la médecine moderne bon
maintenant il faut vacciner tout le
monde mais c'est vrai qu'on est en
retard de tous on ne sait pas
s'organiser
moi moi je vais vous le dire comme je le
crois je pense que ça a été organisé par
des énarques qui n'y comprennent rien ça
aurait été organisé par saint cyr et pas
des militaires on n'en serait pas là
du coup on a fait des contre est contre
et contre publicité de certains vaccins
donc dû gens les gens qui nous écoutent
les français vous savez ça sera
intéressant de voir que le niveau
médical du français moyen
ils étaient là avant la crise il ya un
an il est là maintenant ils connaissent
tout absolument tout ils sont une des
ces évidences qui fait que d'un coup on
doit vacciner tout le monde ça doit être
l'objectif
or ces timides et on y va doucement et
on réfléchit doucement et on se dit
alors la halle et les plus les mois etc
et puis en mois de juin peut-être que en
attendant la sq il faut juste que vous
sachiez c'est qu'il ya 6 % des cas que
nous avons en ile-de-france qui sont
déjà du variant brésilien et donc du
coup mine de rien nous sommes en train
de jouer la saisonnalité de cette
saloperie d'accord avec un plateau parce
qu'on a atteint un plateau l'a donc là
on a un plateau qui va diminuer en mai
juin et à tous les coups ça va revenir à
l'automne c'est par entendable c'est pas
possible
et c'est là où il ya un rôle régalien de
l'état et et de patriotisme de la part
de ceux qui organisent le système de
santé dont d'où la une du monde qu'on a
regardé ensemble avant de commencer avec
cette nécessité d'avoir des vaccins qui
sont fabriqués en france qui sont faits
en france donc on retombe sur ce
problème de souveraineté
et c'est là où en fait vous apercevez
que c'est un virus qui est éminemment
politique qui est éminemment social qui
est un virus qui creusent toutes les
inégalités et la première qui est une
égalité économique et d'accès aux
médicaments et ça et ça c'est vraiment
le noeud du problème tant qu'on aura pas
d une vaccination massive et je suis
désolé nous ne l'avons toujours pas tant
qu'on n'aura pas une vaccination massive
et de tout le monde
on n'y arrivera pas il n'y arrivera pas
et j'ai terminé votre propos avec cette
réaction d'hervé sur youtube pelo
ministre de la santé pour desquamation
voilà c'est vrai au moins supporters
vont avec
si sûrement beaucoup d'autres ça m'est
très clairement il faut accélérer la
vaccination mais la france commence à
rattraper les pays du tiers monde et les
pays moins développés
la france a rattrapé le maroc en taux de
vaccination par exemple alors c'est pas
extraordinaire mais c'est un premier pas
et est-ce qu'il faut aller chercher
d'autres vaccins pour pour en avoir
davantage
vous savez que le président les
républicains de la région sud provence
alpes côte d'azur
lui il dit et ben moi comme je suis allé
chercher des masques à l'étranger
maintenant je vais chercher du spoutnik
vais écouter
bon bien aujourd'hui on a une
possibilité nouvelle de d'avoir des
vaccins je vais chercher les vaccins
comme j'allais chercher les masques donc
la réalité c'est que effectivement il
faut vacciner vacciner vacciner tous
ceux qui le veulent ne pas se focaliser
sur ce qu'ils ne veulent pas mais le
faire pour tous ceux qui le veulent
à partir du moment où ils sont ces cures
et qu'il n'y a pas de risque sanitaire
il faut vacciner partout tout le temps
sans arrêt voilà on au musée liés dans
ton précise qu'il est médecin vous êtes
convaincu par cet argument le relaxant
il ya deux clans en dehors de l'europe
qui se font vacciner au spoutnik vais en
tant que médecin en tant que citoyen en
tant que père de famille
moi je ne je ne conseillerais pas le
cinpharm ce tir le vaccin chinois qui
marche très très mal on le voit au chili
et je ne conseillerais pas non plus le
vaccin spotnicks 5
tant que les agences du médicament
indépendante c'est-à-dire la f10 et aux
états unis et l'agencé européenne du
médicament non pas européenne n'ont pas
accès aux données sources
1 parce qu'il faut bien comprendre un
truc c'est que la f10 aux etats unis l
agence européenne du médicament peut
faire un bras d'honneur aux politiques
en revanche en russie le président de l'
agence du médicament russe ne peut pas
faire un bras d'honneur à poutine
il n'y a pas d'indépendance de
l'évaluation du médicament est pour
l'instant les agences indépendantes du
médicaments en europe et aux états unis
n'ont pas eu accès aux données source
c'est-à-dire aux dossiers des patients
sur lequel on a testé le vaccin donc vu
les trous qu'on a dans le dossier
d'évaluation du spoutnik 5 il n'est pas
raisonnable de le prescrire au moment où
nous parlons alors peut-être que
l'agencé européenne du médicament va
avoir accès à la totalité des dossiers
mais ça n'a pas le cas pour le moment
et dans ce cadre là moi je ne conseille
pas de prendre du spoutnik 5 aujourd'hui
non monsieur qu est ce qui est ce qui
est stupéfiant c'est que vous avez quand
même un président de région il ya treize
régions en france donc c'est quand même
un personnage de l'état qui remet en
cause l'organisation de l'état le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand est
furieux et il a soutenu depuis le départ
hydroxy chloroquine en disant que
c'était un rom a d'extraordinaire donc
la corse est dans la même veine d'accord
c'est dans la même veine et et en plus
il est médecin si j'ai bien compris ce
que je savais la le cv de muselier bon
c'est c'est un vrai problème de
patriotisme parce que à la limite que
nous qui sommes rien on dise ah ils ont
qu'à acheter du spoutnik tout le monde
s'en fou etc
mais quand vous êtes un personnage de
l'état comme l'est le président de
région il peut pas il peut pas dire ça
d'autant que ça laurent alexandre vient
de le dire fort justement il ya un
problème majeur c'est que on ne sait pas
exactement ce qu'il ya dans ce vaccin
alors pour le coup on remet en cause la
stratégie cas où on a des dossiers comme
ça on l'a suspendu évalué vtt par des
résidents des indépendants etc accédera
et puis là on dit comme si alors c'est
marrant parce que c'est très un il ya un
côté très ancestrales et très primitif à
tout ça c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression qu'on a le bruit de le
druide qui va arriver comme ça avec la
tisane qui va faire qu'on va guérir tout
le monde et que c'est un truc finalement
très simple non
c'est quelque chose de très compliqué
parce que nous avons un virus qui a
passé la barrière animal
il a fallu des siècles pour passer cette
barrière animal il est arrivé sur terre
on a une véritable nouvelle maladie sur
terre qui est en train de faire un
cataclysme social économique et
politique très bien et là vous avez donc
le druide
n'est ce pas russe qui dit j'ai trouvé
un accent personne sait ce que c'est et
là vous avez des gens qui commencent à
encenser ce médecin il faut atterrir
faut être un peu raisonnable
autant je suis premier critique sur
l'organisation vraiment d'escargots et
au double diesel qui a été fait pour
vacciner les gens mais autant vous ne
pouvez pas dire aux gens écouter
vaccinez vous
surtout on a mis je sais que c'est une
charge administrative considérable tous
ces curseurs ces verrous qu'on a mis
pour pouvoir prendre un médicament et ça
demande du temps ok mais il faut le
respecter et surtout quand vous êtes un
personnage de l'état
voyez et je comprends pas puisqu'il ses
nerfs dans dix ans j'ai pas de vaccin
moi et je sais pas s'il a pris la parole
pour dire à nice il ya quatre mille
doses il ya 58 personnes qui y sont
allés voilà il peut peut-être que renaud
muselier aurait pu prendre son micro là
il dire allez vous faire allez vous
faire vacciner est toujours sur les
règles en vigueur est ce que vous pensez
laurent récente qu'il faut maintenir la
réservation de l'astra zeneca aux plus
de 55 ans donc pour l'instant c'était
raisonnable mais en réalité on commence
à avoir des thromboses 1 chez les plus
de 55 ans donc la limite d'âge sans
doute dans n'a pas de sens et les
données récentes laisse penser qu'il
faut le donner à tout le monde
non mais pardon des thromboses faut pas
exagérer a cessé ses mots c'est moins
d'une dizaine faut alors il ya il ya des
théories sur justement des des protéines
qui font la coagulation qui serait
activé etc
mais c'est en dessous de ce que fait la
pilule contraceptive en dessous de ce
que fait le tabac en dessous d'accord
donc vous pouvez déposer vos arrivée aux
urgences vers dieu d'azur et rambo et et
aucun on les verra d'une main francs et
les c'est rarissime voudra réussir donc
vous voyez vous ébranlé en fait tout un
truc c'est mais il ya une vraie psychose
c'est une réalité
c'est il faut qu elle fait partie du jeu
elle est regrettable mais pratiquement
j'ai même envie de vous dire ben voilà
faut changer le fusil d'épaulé le le
problème est la vérole ces nouvelles
vous avez failli soeur qu'il fait
maintenant du chantage puisqu'il
augmente ses prix d'accord
après vous avez une nouvelle rumeur qui
est arrivé avec juste weiser caddie
faudrait peut-être une troisième dose
pour des malades très spécifique
immunodéprimés qu'on eut des greffes etc
c'est ça c'est ça s'est répandu mais
vraiment comme l'a alors la traînée de
kérosène sur la piste ça a foutu le feu
partout les gens moi je vais non tel
coup de téléphone que j'ai reçu ce
week-end en disant il nous faut une
troisième dose mode mais on on a besoin
et c'est là et c'est là où retombent
sur une problématique qui est très forte
qui ait fait qu'on ne croit plus parce
que vous avez à la tête des gens que ce
soit le comité vaccinale fisher et
compagnie etc
ils n'ont pas été de bons communicants
ils ont été très mauvais ce qui fait
qu'il ya une perte de confiance est bon
il n'est jamais trop tard pour refaire
il faut espérer que notre pays
rebondissent il faut être patriote
à l'heure actuelle pour sauver sauver et
sortir du marasme
et bien cet appel au patriotisme sera le
mot de la fin de cette émission merci
beaucoup à tous les deux merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous demain
pour une nouvelle édition de point de
vue
[Musique]